[Musique]
alors bonjour on est content d'être ici
parce que ce qui nous unit beaucoup
nicolas et moi c'est qu'on a un mot qui
est tatoué sur le coeur
c'est le mot entrepreneuriat parce que
ç'a changé nos vies ça complètement
changé notre vie littéralement
l'entrepreneuriat avant tout pour moi
c'est une question d'idées de patients
et d'histoire et je suis convaincu que
si on connaissait l'histoire de tous les
produits qu'on consomme on consommerait
totalement différent
oui et je vais vous raconter mon
histoire en fait moi je viens d'une
famille plutôt modeste j'ai été élevé
dans beaucoup d'émotion quand j'en parle
dans le sous sol de la maison des
grands-parents qui avait été aménagée en
appartement puis moi j'étais convaincu
que j'allais me sortir du sous-sol en
avant très longtemps sur les bancs
d'école moi je voulais est avocate moi
je voulais être médecin moi je voulais
aller à l'université et à l'âge de 13 14
ans mais ma vie a comme basculer parce
que mes parents qui étaient tous des
mauvais de parole mais qui avait
vraiment des croyances différentes des
miennes m'ont appris que non seulement
je n'irai pas longtemps sur les bancs
d'école mais je connais pas mon
secondaire 5 général donc moi ma vie a
vraiment basculé mais en même temps dans
deux mois je crois que j'avais du sang
de bâton j'étais convaincu qu'il y avait
quelque chose de grand qui m'attendait
mais je savais pas quoi
et là j'étais sur le marché du travail
avec un salaire de 7 dollars de l'heure
j'étais sténodactylo on appeler ça comme
ça dans ce temps là et j'étais vraiment
la recherche de quelque chose de grand
et un jour bien j'ai perdu mon emploi
en fait pour vous dire vrai j'ai été
congédié et j'ai vu un gros gros tunnel
noir j'ai juste avec moi dans la vie
avait jamais rien qui vous qui voulaient
marcher avec moi mais savez vous quoi
moi c'est le jour de mon congédiement
que c'est devenu la plus belle journée
de ma vie parce que moi j'ai pensé que
le congédiement c'était la fin mais
c'était pas vrai c'était juste le début
de quelque chose de nouveau ou j'allais
devenir entrepreneur donc moi je suis
partie en affaires le jeu ou dans mon
congédiement avec les actifs suivants
des paiements fin du mois
toujours je me rappelais toujours dans
les moments difficiles je me rappelais
de la célèbre phrase de walt disney qui
dit avery pas des deadlines
moi j'en avais mes paiements fin du mois
j'avais beaucoup d'acharnement beaucoup
d'acharnement piste est pas nécessaire
d'en avoir autant mais j'en avais
normalement mais j'avais de la
persévérance et là je travaillais
travailler je voulais tellement
visibilité je voulais tellement que tout
le monde au québec puisse me connaître
pour faire affaire avec mon entreprise
j'essaie de participer à toutes les
concours possibles et impossibles et un
jour j'ai fait une grande folie j'ai vu
deux
dans ce journal j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
une grande mission commerciale qui
partait en chine avec le premier
ministre lucien bouchard et moi j'avais
quelques contrats québec j'avais
seulement 1 contrairement à toronto même
pas de contrat montréal ce jour là je
suis parti en chine et sa vive quoi j'ai
fait une grosse prière là vient la
veille de mon départ puisque j'ai
demandé au bon dieu c'est que vraiment
que l'avion puisse avoir le vent dans
face pour qu'on puisse rester une heure
de plus de temps dans l'avion pourquoi
parce que 21h22 heures de vol avec 159
entrepreneurs québécois
je me suis dit je vois toutes les
convaincre de faire affaire avec les
portes étaient morts et c'est les
personnes pouvaient débarquer ce
extraordinaire
alors qu'est ce qui t'arrive et oui on a
doublé chiffre d'affaires c'était une
expérience extraordinaire mon entreprise
est vraiment pris beaucoup d'ampleur et
finalement un jour j'ai été acheté par
un très gros groupes mon histoire a fait
la une des journaux
comment je me suis sentie mais très
partagée dans le succès pourquoi parce
qu'à l'époque dans les années début 2000
salut au québec quand on parle d'argent
c'est toujours encore un peu difficile
et puis là bon il y en a qui disait des
phrases comme bon de secrétaire est
millionnaire
j'avais tellement peur du jugement que
j'avais peur de ça mais en même temps
j'ai reçu tellement de messages de gens
qui me disais mon dieu c'est la preuve
que tout est possible avec un cours de
secondaire 5 sténodactylo ou été réussi
à faire une compagnie dans les
technologies internet puis je me suis
dit c'est sûr que je dois avoir une
mission à accomplir mais je ne savais
pas quoi mais je savais quelque chose de
grand m'attendais a définitivement moi
tout a commencé à l'université moi je
voulais être architecte mais j'ai quand
j'ai regardé ce qu'il fallait et surtout
ce que la cote r qu'il fallait pour être
achetés que j'ai su que j'allais pas et
allez on va se
sans blague savais pas que ça pouvait
monter aux seahawks une cote r le montre
moi y avait juste un chef il ya en
fallait deux et on oublie ça mais le
bref j'adore
après par après suis tombé puis je
cherchais un autre programme d'études
puis j'ai décidé de j'adore est acceptée
en sciences politiques parce qu'on est
tous accepté en sciences politiques donc
jeté un d7000 cette année est accepté et
c'est à l'inertie que j'ai découvert
l'entrepreneuriat vous pouvez pas
comprendre à quel point j'ai découvert
un univers qui s'ouvrait qui couvrait le
monde
je voulais inventer la fourchette je
voulais réinventer la chaise je faisais
des plans d'affaires des plans
d'affaires
j'avais deux tendances à l'université il
fallait avoir 60 pour passer une
tendance que je respectais 60.00 tous
les cours la deuxième ça c'est vrai je
fais le meilleur là dedans la deuxième
j'étais le roi des débuts de plans
d'affaires le nombre de plans d'affaires
que j'ai commencé vous comprenez pas de
trois pages après je m'emmerdais mais
vous comprenez pas à quel point j'étais
en fait j'étais en fut un moment
d'assister les cravates un moment donné
c'était je sais pas moi c'était la
compagnie aérienne tout d'un coup je
finis universités puis 1
j'ai un bac en sciences politiques qu'on
m'appelle politologue
je sais toujours pas aujourd'hui ce que
ça fait donc vous imaginez je savais pas
où est appliquée j'ai décidé de me
lancer en affaires avec trois de mes
meilleurs amis on sortait beaucoup on
sortait vraiment beaucoup ça ça peut
justifier les notes du passé et j'avais
remarqué qu'on qu'on les trois ans les
quatre on avait envie de se lancer en
affaires donc on a décidé d'ouvrir un
resto bar
petit conseil d'ami c'est pas parce
qu'on aime manger au restaurant qu'on
peut avoir un restaurant c'est un de ce
conseil comme ça écoutez ça a été mais
dans l'histoire de la restauration
mondiale
ça a été un des plus belles échec sans
blague
les fleurs qu'on a reçue à l'ouverture
n'était pas fan et quand on a fermé ok
vous comprenez pas ici surtout que vous
êtes gentils ouvriers de même en échec
mais bref
mais si mais si au restaurant que j'ai
découvert la popularité de la 25e jour
j'ai offert mes partenaires de les
racheter ils ont refusé
je suis partie du restaurant bredouille
parce que j'ai décidé moi de vendre mes
parts et puis je me suis rappelé dans
une seule phrase que ma mère me disait
moi j'étais en sport étude au basketball
au cégep chef qu'on perdait faisait
nicolas l'important c'est pas le nombre
de fautes tombent ces noms de faux
titres à l'aise
j'ai pris cette phrase la gelée ancré
dans ma mémoire puis je me suis dit mais
cette fois ci je me lançais dans la
vodka savez quoi c'est sur le moteur de
recherche google que ma vie a changé
parce que je chante j'ai tapé cinq
lettres vo des cas à et c'est comme ça
pour votre aîné alors moi je n'ai de
vendre mon entreprise selon me disait la
vie doit être belle et tout ça ben non
moi j'ai fait une dépression pendant
trois mois parce que je me reconnaissais
plus je ne savais plus qui j'étais moi
je mettais beaucoup identifiés dans le
monde des ordres des affaires avec ma
carte d'affaires parce que c'est là que
les gens commencent à me dire tu est
bonne ce fait des bonnes choses et moi
ça m'encourage énormément donc j'étais
tellement mélanger que je savais plus
quoi faire je me retrouvais souvent
curieusement vous allez voir la
synchronicité de la vie je me retrouvais
souvent dans les restaurants cora que
jamais plein de livres avec moi j'ai
j'ai lu lâcher prise
pensé pour lâcher prise avez vous lâcher
prise
est-ce que j'ai lâché prise non je me
suis dit à mme tu as les yeux bruns et
les cheveux bruns et et une entrepreneur
qui tu vas continuer à faire de
l'entrepreneuriat parce que ça me faire
un deuxième succès c'est excessivement
difficile pourquoi ce canton par qui on
eu rien on n'a rien à perdre
mais quand on a un à qui on a peur de le
perdre si on a peur de la gestion du
risque on le fait on ne gère plus le
risque de la même manière donc je me
suis dit qu'est ce que je vais faire
j'ai senti moins que je voulais laisser
mon fils parce que je suis
monoparentales je lui laissais plus qu
un compte de banque
moi je voulais lui laisser un héritage
un héritage plus grand accent qui était
de faire la différence dans la vie des
autres parce que retenu la chose
suivante quand on a un succès c'est bien
aimé le plus grand des succès quand on
en a eu un
c'est faire la différence dans celui
dans le succès dans la prospérité des
autres et là je me suis dit je vais
monter une émission de télévision ça va
s'appeler voir grand puis je veux mettre
en lumière tous les entrepreneurs qui
sont dans leur fond du seul qui tapent
des vous comme votre place sur google et
je vais tout les mettre vraiment en
lumière loges et appeler madame courage
avait besoin de notoriété et est connue
elle au québec comme ça se pouvait pas
je partirai que mon bâton de pèlerin et
2006 aucune émission sur
l'entrepreneuriat au québec j'ai produit
la première émission sur
l'entrepreneuriat au québec j'ai
rencontré 1500 jeunes entrepreneurs qui
avaient chacun trois minutes pour
présenter leur projet j'ai vu des
dénominateurs communs sur ces
entrepreneurs des dénominateurs qui me
ressemblait tellement tout des gens qui
avaient des problèmes afin d'y mots avec
leurs paiements des gens
souffrait d'isolement parce que vous
savez il ya une expression d'anglais qui
dit stop on se sent seul avec nos rêves
et nos ambitions des fois des gens nous
regardent ils comprennent pas ce qu'on
est en train de faire mais c'était tout
des gens qui avaient vraiment les yeux
pétillants et un jour à l'hôtel delta
montréal on est en train de faire les
auditions puis un grand gaillard de 6
pieds 4 qui heureusement un grand
gaillard de 6 pieds 5 qui vient faire
l'audition et tous les juges des
auditions de voir grand tombe en amour
on tombe sous le charme
nicolas je me souviens encore parce que
j'étais productrice animatrice
réalisatrice on faisait tout dans ce
projet là parce que personne n'y croyait
je me souviens encore de ce que tu as
dit on nous dit si on te dit ce n'est
tabou theil comme ça tu disais moi
j'aime monter la meilleure votre
commande
le québec ne sais pas puis c'est la
meilleure votre commande par ce long
mois selon des experts à londres ça
m'avait marqué le camp et quand est
sorti et quand est sorti j'ai dit aux
juges nommés et extraordinaire tout le
monde était unanime oui on le prend j'ai
juste dit un petit budget supplémentaire
pour le maquillage parce que le gonidec
homme a su cerner ce que nous on savait
pas ce qu'il arrivait de la vie ses
planchers de pitou la nuit et moi ça
faisait presque trois ans et demi
laquelle je l'avais des planchers à
l'hôpital sainte-justine je dis pas que
j'aime pas laver les planchers
il ya une limite j'ai un post-doctorant
lavage de plancher aujourd'hui mais bref
c'était ma femme aujourd'hui ma femme ma
copine carreaux mes parents ma soeur qui
m'aidait à traverser toutes ces années
là c'était des ânes éternelle en
religion une sainte trinité on a fait
aussi un plus long plus cher plus
compliqué que prévu tu dis amen
soutenant son affaire
non je mets beaucoup de blagues
aujourd'hui parce que si je racontais
comment je l'avais vécu je serai en
train de pleurer comprenez pas crépon se
sent seul et puis un jour je me suis dit
je me lavais mais plancher savez la
technique du étant pour pourquoi pas
manqué une seule poussière et puis je me
suis dit et que je t'attendais de voir
la business d'un entrepreneuriat qui
commençait à être un des moteurs qui
font payer des jeunes entrepreneurs pour
leur donner des conseils plus ou moins
douteux j'ai tâtonné voir des grandes
entreprises données varient donc pour
des causes entreprenariale mais
finalement ce qui vous laisse d'un logo
sur un building
moi j'étais seul en train de laver les
planchers 17 banques m'ont refusé 17
banques m'ont refusé
vous allez il n'ya pas dix est
maintenant mais certaines banques je
faisais différentes succursales voici la
réponse est la même je parle entre eux
ils se parlent autres je te devenue une
rumeur dans la ville
là comme un gars qui se promènent qui
veut qu alan doss cas bref mais bien un
jour je l'avais le plancher puis je me
suis dit si j'étais tellement enragé si
un jour j'ai la chance de réussir je
vais tout faire pour ne serait ce qui
est dit un parent dont un seul jeune
entrepreneur ce temps là ce moment là
est venu beaucoup plus rapidement que
prévu
quelques années plus tard j'ai eu un
petit bébé mais victoria et j'ai décidé
d'écrire un livre parce que je voulais
la fenêtre dans un environnement
différent que ce que j'ai connu et je
voulais qu'elle se rappelle dans j'adore
dire elle a 16 mois dont 3 4 mois quand
il va lire mon livre que est intelligent
que ce que vous voulez mais je voulais
qu'elles sachent qu est-ce que ses
parents ont fait qu'est-ce que ses
parents ont dû en train prendre comme
chemin pour pour atteindre où ils sont
rendus aujourd'hui je voulais pas
qu'elle est les dix ans oui mes parents
ils ont une dette business ça fonctionne
bien
je voulais surtout qu'à pense car oui
mais pas avant il ya des soirs qui
mangeaient pas c'est ça que je voulais
qu'elle se rappelle est très rapidement
dans ce livre la baie je me suis dit
qu'est ce que je peux pas ça je peux pas
je serai raconter mon histoire il faut
que faut que je lance une perche au
monde des affaires il faut que le modèle
dead entrepreneuriale change et c'est là
que dans ce livre que j'ai écrit que
adopté un kiné et c'est là que te
présenter tout ça tout le monde en parle
exactement
oui en fait je me souviens de ce
moment-là que j'ai vécu avec toi tu m'a
appelé jusqu'à 2 heures du matin mais
vous savez quand nicolas m'a envoyé son
manuscrit avec son
j'aurais dû me faire un selphy parce que
j'avais l'air d'alice cooper tellement
mascarade écoulé parce que j'avais
pleuré
pourquoi parce que mon nom apparaissait
plusieurs fois vous savez des fois on
fait la différence dans la vie des
autres mais il ya une expression que
j'adore un qui dit données sans attendre
mais nicolas avait reçu sans oublier que
ça m'avait beaucoup ému parce que je me
dise exactement ce que je veux que mon
fils se souviennent quand je serai plus
là qui vois que mon nom apparaît dans
les livres des jeunes entrepreneurs à
succès et le camp gilles adopting j'ai
dit nicolas je vais être la cofondatrice
je veux qu'on fasse ensemble les amis
collègues dont on va chercher des
partenaires institutionnels illégitime
collège et qui ne sont plus que toi on
va quand même on peut on peut pas me
dire comme ça la ramène c'est ça alors j
10 kg quelques années de plus que toi
j'ai dit faut que ça serve donc j'ai
utilisé mes contacts amis dans la vie
c'est pas juste qu'est ce qu'on connaît
c'est qui on connaît qui peut faire la
différence
j'étudie quelques contacts j'ai réussi à
présenter un mycologue vraiment des
super de grandes entreprises qu'on a
besoin quand on se lance en affaires
et puis l'on ne travaille et a lancé le
mouvement d'opt-in puis moi d'obtenir
pourquoi c'est venu me chercher parce
qu'ils coûtent est bien le nom adopté
pourquoi ça s'appelle adopting janicot
lost extraordinaire cette marque de
commerce là parce que quand on adopte
quelqu'un c'est parce qu'une notion
d'amour c'est parce qu'on aime la
personne on l'apprend dans notre famille
adopté ça veut dire prendre soin d'une
personne ça veut dire parfois laisser sa
place pour donner vraiment la lumière à
une autre personne donc perso dans le
domaine entrepreneuriat cette notion lot
d'amour je trouvais que ça rend tout ça
rendait vraiment l'entrepreneuriat de
manière très humaine puis honnêtement la
meilleure personne dont vous expliquer
c'est quoi le mouvement c'est nicolas
écoute adopte actionner d'un rêve mais
c'est devenu une réalité si ça que
j'adore de l'entrepreneuriat aussi la
puissance d'une idée moi ce que ça donne
c'est un mouvement personnel c'est ce
que j'aurais rêvé recevoir quand je
l'avais le plancher c'est aussi simple
que ça il ya beaucoup d'autres qui
existe et dieu merci il ya des bourses
du mentorat
mais il y avait aucune expérience unique
sur une période plus ou moins longue de
12 mois qui englobait tout ce qu'un
jeune entrepreneur avait besoin
qu'est ce qu'un jeune entrepreneur a
besoin d'un salaire un salaire un
entrepreneur a besoin d'un salaire comme
tout le monde d'ailleurs
donc on offre un salaire à nos jeunes
entrepreneurs c'est pas le luxe c'est ce
que je faisais quand je l'avais le
plancher ses 25 mètres dans la parano
mais moins avoir reçu 25 mille dollars
par année quand je touchais le plancher
pour me concentrer sur mon plan d'eau
fait plutôt que torche et des planches
et là croyez moi c'est comme si je
venais de gagner à la loterie
ensuite on donne une sorte de mentorat
réseautage mais avec des ténors du monde
des affaires
on a la chance d'avoir un déboucheur le
fondateur de couche tard guy cormier le
pdg de desjardins clair pour merlot bref
tous des noms qui font rêver tous les
jeunes entrepreneurs mais je voulais
faire ce fameux lien là entre un jeune
entrepreneur et six entrepreneurs à
succès là ils vont aller rencontrer une
fois par mois une fois par mois
rencontré alain bouchard
une fois dans sa vie c'est une chance
unique ensuite on va donner des
formations les formations sur mesure
pour les entrepreneurs pourquoi parce
que moi au travers mon parcours j'ai
appliqué quatre fois dans quatre
universités différentes pour faire ma
maîtrise en administration des affaires
et les quatre universités m'ont refusé
pourquoi parce que j'avais 60.00 de
moyenne en sciences politiques
mais je trouve ça ridicule ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire des notes finalement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
donc on donne des formations sur mesure
on donne des formations sur l'innovation
sur l'importance des bonnes pratiques en
affaires bref on on les y nombre de
formations spécialisées pour des jeunes
entrepreneurs et dernièrement on leur
fait revivre
on leur fait vivre une réelle expérience
en affaires on les place sur des
conseils d'administration pourquoi
voyais un moment donné j'ai dû faire un
conseil d'administration pour
m'accompagner
dès le départ parce que je voulais être
bien entouré mais charles pasqua parce
que quand tu laves des planches et
personne ne veut de toi sur les conseils
d'administration on s'entend c'est
catastrophique
donc non les places sur les conseils
d'administration at cet observatoire
pour qu'ils puissent vivre le moment
vive c'est quoi le ferais
entrepreneuriat donc c'est une
expérience entrepreneuriale unique sur
12 mois où on offre un salaire du
réseautage mentorat de très haut niveau
de la formation
une réelle expérience dans le monde des
affaires
on a fait notre premier recours déjà 400
jeunes ont proposé jeunes entrepreneurs
émergents ont proposé leur candidature
25 entrepreneurs ont été adoptés cinq
privilégiés sont adoptés personnellement
par des grandes personnalités du monde
des affaires
honnêtement je tiens à te le dis quand
je t'ai vu rentrer faire tourner
audition avoir grand je savais que tu
seras gagnant flamboyant de la série
télévisée j'étais contente parce que le
québec m'ont tellement d'inspiration de
héros et de modèles surendettés nicolas
mais j'ai beaucoup d'émotion pour te
dire que le hasard c'est trouver les
gens qui savent s'en servir puis je
pense qu'on a réussi à s'en servir tous
les deux on a fait le mouvement adopting
puis je pense que ce qu'on est en train
de faire c'est le concept de l'effet
papillon qui dit que chaque petit
battement d'aile si petit soit il va
finir un jour ou l'autre à faire une
grande différence et c'est ce qu'on fait
parce que nos entrepreneurs émergents
qu'ils ont ce fond adoptées par des
grandes personnel dès qu'un peu ils vont
devenir grand ils ont la responsabilité
sociale et morale d'adopter à leur tour
on veut vraiment faire tout le concept
de l'effet papillon et je suis convaincu
qu'on peut faire la différence parce que
sachez qu'une société qui manque
d'entrepreneurs c'est une société qui
s'appauvrit et je vais finir avec en
vous disant une phrase qui est très
importante pour moi un entrepreneur
c'est pas seulement un créateur d'emploi
créateurs de richesse c'est avant tout
un créateur de fierté merci beaucoup
plus
[Applaudissements]